the basic question is does life exist
beyond Earth scientists who are called
astrobiologists are trying to find that
out right now
most astrobiologists are trying to
figure out if there's microbial life on
Mars or in the ocean under the frozen
surface of Jupiter's moon Europa or in
the liquid hydrocarbon lakes that we
found on Saturn's moon Titan
but one group of astrobiologists works
on SETI SETI is the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence and SETI
researchers are trying to detect some
evidence that intelligent creatures
elsewhere have used technology to build
a transmitter of some sort but how
likely is it that they will manage to
find a signal there are certainly no
guarantees when it comes to SETI but
something called the Drake Equation
named after Frank Drake can help us
organize our thinking about what might
be required for a successful detection
if you've dealt with equations before
then you probably expect that there will
be a solution to the equation a right
answer the Drake Equation however is
different because there are so many
unknowns it has no right answer as we
learn more about our universe and our
place within it some of the unknowns get
better known and we can estimate an
answer a bit better but there won't be a
definite answer to the Drake Equation
until SETI succeeds or something else
proves that Earthlings are the only
intelligent species in our portion of
the cosmos in the meantime it is really
useful to consider the unknowns the
Drake Equation attempts to estimate the
number of technological civilizations in
the Milky Way galaxy we call that in
with whom we could make contact and it's
usually written as n equals R star
multiplied by F sub P multiplied by n
sub e multiplied by F sub L multiplied
by F sub I multiplied by F sub C and
lastly multiplied by capital L all those
factors multiplied together help to
estimate the number of technological
civilizations that we might be able to
detect right now our star is the rate at
which stars have been born in the Milky
Way galaxy over the last few billion
years so it's a number that is stars per
year our galaxy is 10 billion years old
and early in its history stars formed at
a different rate all of the F factors
are fractions each one must be less than
or equal to 1 F sub P is the fraction of
stars that have planets n sub E is the
average number of habitable planets in
any planetary system F sub L is the
fraction of planets on which life
actually begins and F sub I is the
fraction of all those life-forms that
develop intelligence F sub C is the
fraction of intelligent life that
develops a civilization that decides to
use some sort of transmitting technology
and finally L the longevity factor on
average how many years do those
transmitters continue to operate
astronomers aren't now almost able to
tell us what the product of the first
three terms is we're now finding
exoplanets almost everywhere the
fractions dealing with life and
intelligence and technological
civilizations are ones that many many
experts ponder but nobody knows for sure
so far we only know of one place in the
universe where life exists and that's
right here on earth
in the next couple of decades as we
explore Mars and Europa and Titan the
discovery of any kind of life
air will mean that life will be abundant
in the Milky Way because if life
originated twice within this one solar
system it means it was easy and given
similar conditions elsewhere life will
happen so the number two is a very
important number here scientists
including SETI researchers often tend to
make very crude estimates and
acknowledge that there are very large
uncertainties in these estimates in
order to make progress we think we know
that our star and n sub E are both
numbers that are closer to 10 then say
to one and all the F factors are less
than one some of them may be much less
than one but of all these unknowns the
biggest unknown is Kel so perhaps the
most useful version of the Drake
Equation is simply to say that n is
approximately equal to L the information
in this equation is very clear unless L
is large and will be small but you know
you can also turn that around
if SETI succeeds in detecting a signal
in the near future after examining only
a small portion of the stars in the
Milky Way then we learn that L on
average must be large otherwise we
couldn't have succeeded so easily a
physicist named Philip Morrison
summarized this by saying that SETI is
the archaeology of the future by this II
meant that because the speed of light is
finite any signals detected from distant
technologies will be telling us about
their past by the time they reach us but
because L must be large for a successful
detection we also learn about our future
particularly that we can have a long
future we've developed technologies that
can send signals into space and humans
to the moon but we've also developed
technologies that can destroy the
environment that can wage war with
weapons and biological terrorism
in the future will our technology help
stabilize our planet and our population
leading to a very long lifetime for us
or will we destroy our world and its
inhabitants
after only a brief appearance on the
cosmic stage I encourage you to consider
the unknowns in this equation why don't
you make your own estimates for these
unknowns and see what you come up with
Fran compare that with the estimates
made by Frank Drake Carl Sagan other
scientists or your neighbors remember
there's no right answer not yet